>>> IN OUR MONEY LEAD, SOUTHWEST
AIRLINES IS BACK IN THE HOT SEAT
OVER ITS EPIC TRAVEL MELTDOWN
OVER THE HOLIDAYS.
ON TOP OF HEARING FROM ANGRY
CUSTOMERS WHO HAD FLIGHTS
CANCELED OR LUGGAGE MISPLACED,
TODAY TOP SOUTHWEST OFFICIALS
ALSO ANSWERED TO LAWMAKERS WHO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THIS DEBACLE
NEVER HPZ AGAIN.
CNN'S GABE COHEN HAS MORE NOW ON
TODAY'S HEARING AND A PROMISE
FROM SOUTHWEST.
>> LET ME BE CLEAR.
WE MESSED UP.
>> Reporter: SOUTHWEST'S CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER IN THE HOT
SEAT FACING LAWMAKERS OVER THEIR
DECEMBER MELTDOWN.
>> I AM DEEPLY SORRY.
>> I HUMBLY APOLOGIZE.
>> I APOLOGIZE ONCE AGAIN.
>> IT WAS A FAILURE EPIICALLY
FROM TOP TO BOTTOM.
>> Reporter: THE PILOTS UNION
SAYS IT SOUNDED THE ALARM ABOUT
SOUTHWEST'S FLAWED SYSTEMS FOR
YEARS BUT WERE IGNORED.
>> POOR PERFORMANCE WAS
CONDONED.
EXCUSES WERE MADE.
PROCESSES ATROPHIED.
CORE VALUES WERE FORGOTTEN.
>> WERE DIDN'T YOU DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT?
>> THANK YOU, SENATOR.
WE WERE ADDRESSING PART OF THOSE
ISSUES.
OBVIOUSLY, IT WAS UNSUCCESSFUL
WITH REGARD TO SOME OF THE CREW
SCHEDULING, WE HADN'T INVESTED
IN THOSE AREAS.
>> WELL, AGAIN, BECAUSE YOU DID
NOT LISTEN TO THOSE WARNINGS
CATASTROPHIC CONDITIONS WERE
CREATED FOR PASSENGERS BY THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS ALL ACROSS
OUR COUNTRY.
>> Reporter: THE AIRLINE VOWING
TO DO BETTER WITH A SOFTWARE
UPDATE TO THEIR SCHEDULING
SYSTEM GOING LIVE TOMORROW.
THEY'LL UPGRADE THEIR WINTER
RESILIENCY AND ARE WORKING ON A
TOP BOTO BOTTOM FIX.
>> UNDOUBTLID IT WILL BE IN THE
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
BUT IT WON'T BE TILL MARCH WE'LL
HAVE FINISHED THE ASSESSMENT OF
HOW MUCH AND WHERE.
>> Reporter: THE AIRLINE
CANCELED MORE THAN 16,000
FLIGHTS, STRANDING MORE THAN 2
MILLION PASSENGERS OVER TEN DAYS
IN DECEMBER.
MOST COULD NOT REACH CUSTOMER
SERVICE FOR HELP.
>> SO YOU WON'T GUARANTEE THAT
IN A CANCELED FLIGHT, ESPECIALLY
IN AN INSTANCE LIKE THAT, THAT
ANYBODY WILL BE ABLE TO REACH A
LIVE PERSON AT SOUTHWEST?
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE TELLING ME?
>> SENATOR, ON A DAY LIKE TODAY
OR ANALOGOUS TODAY, YES, WE WILL
BE BE BE ABLE.
IN AN EXACT REPEAT OF THAT
SITUATION I APOLL GILES, THERE'S
NO WAY WE COULD STAFF THAT HIGH.
>> Reporter: SOUTHWEST SAYS
THEY'VE REIMBURSED 273,000
CUSTOMERS WITH LESS THAN 11,000
TO GO.
>> BUT THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT
HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED MOST
REECHTLY AND WITHIN THE D.O.T.
TIMELINES OF 30 DAYS FOR
PROCESSING ALL OF THOSE.
>> Reporter: THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE, SENATOR MARIA
CANTWELL, CRITICAL OF SOUTHWEST
CEO'S BOB JORDAN'S ABSENCE FROM
THE HEARING.
>> YOUR CEO DIDN'T WANT TO SHOW
UP.
>> Reporter: THE AIRLINE TELLS
CNN HE HAD A SCHEDULING
CONFLICT.
NOW, SOME LAWMAKERS ALSO CALLED
OUT THE FAA FOR THEIR SYSTEM
FAILURE THAT CAUSED THAT
NATIONAL GROUND STOP LAST MONTH.
BUT THE AGENCY ITSELF WAS NOT ON
THE PANEL TODAY.
NEXT WEEK THEY'LL HAVE THEIR
TURN IN FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE
WITH THE FAA'S ACTING
ADMINISTRATOR SET TO TESTIFY ON
WEDNESDAY.
AND JAKE, THERE ARE SURE BE TO
BE MANY TOUGH QUESTIONS NOT JUST
ABOUT THAT GROUND STOP B